- On this episode,
storytelling superstar
Morgan Spurlock stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 256
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm super fired up
for this phenomenal guest,
it's ironic, this is really
the first time we're jamming.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Gary] We've interacted
a little on Twitter.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- Then we ran into each other--
- On a plane.
- On a plane, I was like
"Hey, you should come and"--
No, the best part is,
like that you walked by
and then I DM'd you, I was like
"Hey, you should be a guest
on The #AskGaryVee Show."
And you were like, "Sure".
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- And here we are,
two weeks later,
Morgan, why don't you
tell the one person from the
Vayner Nation who
doesn't know who you are,
how you describe yourself now
and we'll get into this show?
We're gonna have,
Facebook if you're watching.
So what are we doing,
taking phone calls from where?
Facebook?
So Instagram peeps,
go over to Facebook Live
if you wanna get
your questions in.
Put your phone
numbers into Facebook.
Morgan and I are gonna
take four or five calls,
depending on how much we yap.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- But for that
one and half person
who doesn't know who you are.
- Yeah my name
is Morgan Spurlock.
I am a filmmaker,
a producer, a writer,
but mostly I am a professional
storyteller is what I do.
- [Gary] That's
how you go with...
- Yeah.
- Which makes sense.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- So, Morgan, take...
before we go into questions,
I wanna get some background.
- Not to be confused with
like an amateur storyteller.
(laughter)
- Listen, it's really crazy--
- [Morgan] That means I should
get paid once in a while,
that's the good part.
- [Gary] That's the key?
- Not all the time but sometimes
I actually get paid for it.
- [Gary] Well you know
what, it's funny, I think
professional storytellers
just get paid, right?
Like I think they
can come from anywhere.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- Whether they make
big Hollywood films or
if they make an
Instagram channel.
- [Morgan] Could be
anywhere, that's right.
- So take me all the way back,
when did you realize
you were a storyteller?
Were you the kind of
kid that was a movie buff?
- Oh yeah.
- [Gary] You wanted to
be Steven Spielberg when
you were a kid?
Give it to me.
- When I was a kid
growing up in West Virginia,
I mean, for as
long as I can remember
I loved movies, I loved TV,
I loved the entertainment
business in general.
And all I ever wanted
to do was make movies.
And, for as far back as I can
remember, five, six years old,
like that was my dream,
and now here I am,
you know, 41 years later
and it's my life and
it's awesome to kind of see
just how this all came to be.
- So you're 41 years old?
- [Morgan] 46 years old.
- 46 so at five, got it.
Okay so what
about West Virginia.
I don't think of that as
like L.A. or New York yeah.
- [Morgan] Hot bed
of entertainment.
That is the hot bed of
the entertainment business.
- [Gary] And
this is now, you know
30, 40 years ago,
right 35 years ago.
- I had amazing parents, like
my mom and dad, you
know, God bless these guys,
they are the great,
I was just talking to my mom
as I was falling down
on your street outside.
Nice street by the way.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Like outside
there are like giant,
there's giant construction work,
there's like a giant rat,
so there's obviously
something going
wrong in your building
because there's a
giant inflatable rat outside.
- One of these things
that's union stuff, got it.
- [Morgan] Union things,
union things.
So I was talking to my
mom right before I came in,
but when I was
growing up in West Virginia,
I had these two amazing
parents that love the arts,
were so supportive of the arts.
I was the youngest of
three ballet dancing brothers.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah my oldest
brother, Craig, went on
to become a professional dancer
as did my middle brother.
- [Gary] That's cool,
my favorite football--
- It is not the cool thing
to be doing in West Virginia
but an awesome thing like have
parents who will support you
saying, "if that's what you
want to do, we're on board."
- So what's
interesting about that is
my all time favorite
football player is Al Toon.
And what he would do in
the off as a wide receiver
in the 80's was go, I mean
this was a football player,
and he did ballet and he
equates a lot of his success
to that.
- It gave me so
much coordination.
It gave me so much confidence.
It made me a
much better athlete.
- It made you confident
because when kids were like,
"You do ballet," you
had to figure out how to
rebuttal that?
- That's right.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It gave me a much
better sense of humor
because I would usually
just make fun of myself...
- [Gary] Of course.
For doing it so
I think the self deprecation,
it's kind of
lived on in my life.
- [Gary] So what's
the first break,
or what's the
start of your career?
How does this happen?
Do you go to school for it?
What happened?
- I think it was when
I got into film school.
- [Gary] And where was that?
- I went to Southern Cal,
first I went to Southern Cal
hoping to get into
the USC film school.
- So you were
able to get into USC.
- I got into USC
Broadcast Journalism.
- [Gary] Which is huge.
- Which is huge, yeah.
- You were like
"Holy shit!" Like "Yes!"
- I'm going to USC but I
didn't get into the film school
but every semester, I kept
applying for the film school,
and every semester I kept
getting rejected from the film--
- Yes, they're like
"You'll never make it."
- Yeah, got rejected five
times from the USC film school
finally, the
last time, I was like
"I gotta apply somewhere else."
Like I keep putting
all my eggs in this basket,
and the shittiest part,
like, here's what an idiot
I was at the time,
I wouldn't apply to
UCLA just out of principle.
- [Gary] Right.
- Because after
going to USC it was like,
"I can't go to USC"--
- [Gary] Yeah, UCLA, yeah.
- What and idiot I
was, what an idiot.
Yeah because
UCLA is beautiful like
USC is in the
middle of Watts like
it's in the middle
of downtown Los Angeles.
UCLA's over in
Westwood, the most beautiful
provincial campus ever,
but I wouldn't apply there.
So I applied to
NYU and I got in.
I came to New York,
been here since 1991.
- [Gary] So you got into NYU...
- [Morgan} And never left.
- And never left.
So what happens next?
- Well I mean I think NYU, the
best part about this school
and New York City in general is,
New York City is really
good at trimming the fat
and I think it's a great city
that automatically helps you,
A, either find your place
in the business you're in,
find your place in
what you want to do.
- Or get the hell out.
- [Morgan] Or get out.
And I think the film
school also did that, is it
really forced me
to come in and focus
and you know, bust
my ass through school
and kinda get what I wanted.
- [Gary] Were you able to
look around and be like,
"Oh that kid's talented,
she's talented."
Like did it kind of
give you perspective.
- [Morgan] Listen, I went to
film school with kids who were
infinitely more
gifted than I was,
who were infinitely more
talented, better storytellers,
better DPs,
artists, like proper artists,
who are now really
great real estate brokers,
and really great accountants,
you know people who--
- [Gary] So what do you equate
your ability to break through
in what everybody aspired
to do in a world where they
didn't achieve that
and you did, like honestly?
- I think, I gotta be honest---
- Especially because this
is an entrepreneur format.
- Tenacity, I think a
lot of it is tenacity.
- [Gary] You willed it?
- I think, you know, it's
not you not only willing it,
but you don't quit.
I think quitting is easy.
That's the other thing is
that a lot of people give up.
Quitting is the
easiest thing in the world
and I just, I don't know--
- [Gary] Win.
I grew up with parents,
amazing parents, who were like
"Whatever you
start, you finish."
- [Gary] Yeah.
- You never like,
no matter what it was,
like if I had wanted to quit
baseball, they were like,
"Nope, you're
finishing the whole season."
I was never able
to quit anything.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- And I grew up with my
father, who was an entrepreneur
who started a
business out of our garage
that grew into a huge business,
and so, I mean for me,
it was always about,
I've gotta stay the course.
Gotta see it through.
- So what's the
first break in MS's career?
- [Morgan] First real,
I mean first real break,
there were so many great ones.
Like right out of film school,
like the very
first job I ever got was
being a P.A. on
The Professional,
which I look back as
like being such like a...
because it was like,
I was being, I was an intern at
Robert De Niro's
production company,
down at the Tribeca Film
Center, at the film center,
and I kept, I kept,
you know, badgering
all of the other
film productions there
you know like,
"Can I get a job?"
I was about to graduate,
I had no employment.
My mom and dad are
like, "You better find a job."
- [Gary] Right, "We're
not paying for shit."
- "We're not gonna be there,
we're not helping you,
"you better find a job."
- [Gary] Yep.
- And so every day I kept going
to the production offices,
I was like, "Hey,
are you hiring anybody,
"you hiring anybody?"
Finally I went to the, it was,
I had two weeks left of school,
and, like, the
production coordinator for,
for Léon, was what the
film was called at the time,
The Professional, what
it became when it came out,
said, "Ugh, Morgan,
do you speak Spanish?"
I said, "Sí, mi
español es muy bien!"
And they said, "we need a
P.A. who can speak Spanish."
I said, "Okay,
yes, I'm your guy."
So they hired me.
So I was like, "Oh my God,
I got a job, this is fantastic."
- [Gary] Was that the only
sentence you knew in Spanish?
- [Morgan] No,
I knew a few more.
Like--
- Okay.
¿Dónde está la biblioteca?
Mi lavas es embrión muy grande.
- [Gary] Okay, so
you had something.
- Oh, me gusta su perro.
You know, it's like--
- Now you're just bragging.
Stop.
(laughing)
- But I knew, I
knew it would play,
I knew enough words where I
could bullshit my way into it.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So cut to
about a month later
as we're in production,
and we're way up on
the upper west side,
in like Washington Heights,
and we're shooting a scene,
and all of a sudden this woman
is screaming at the person,
she's like "ah la la la, la!"
Screaming at the production
coordinator in Spanish,
and they're like,
"Uh, we need Morgan
"to come down to
the corner right now."
So I come down to the
corner and she's screaming,
and yelling, and
pointing, and they're like,
"What is, what is she saying?"
And I was like,
"She's really mad."
(Gary laughs)
"She's..." I'm
listening, and I'm just like,
"she says you people--"
- [Gary] "Bad people."
- "And all of this--"
- [Gary] "Is bad."
- "You need to go."
And you're like,
"You don't understand what
"she's saying at all!"
I said, "I'm
understanding pieces!"
And they're
like, "Get outta here!"
(laughing) But by that
point I'd already kinda
ingratiated my way into the job,
so I didn't get fired,
they kept me around,
but, you know,
I didn't quite tell the,
tell the whole truth
in my Spanish abilities.
- And you're so right, right,
it's always building blocks.
What was the big
break that is like,
the Hollywood headline,
or the, the thing that every,
like, in the limited time we
have together, what was the--
- [Morgan] You know,
the biggest thing that happened
was like, when
we made Supersize Me
and that went to Sundance,
I mean it changed everything.
Like, I made a movie--
- What were you
doing before that?
- [Morgan] I, I had sold--
- Right, because that's
obviously when I--
- Well that was the thing,
back in 1999
I started my first company.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Which was a web-based company
called The
Interactive Consortium,
where I was, you know, I was
in the middle of the tech boom.
- [Gary] Sure.
- I said,
I wanna create a company that
produces programming online,
- [Gary] Yes.
- and then springboard it
off to film or television.
- [Gary] Understood.
- And so as everybody
was raising money,
Den, Sudo, Pop, UBO,
UGO, Icebox.
- [Gary] Yes, yes, yes.
- And these
companies were raising
hundreds of millions of dollars.
I put together my business plan,
and we were trying
to raise about eight,
we had a few people
that were on the hook,
we were about to close,
and then March 2000 happened,--
- [Gary] Right.
- and everything went "pow."
All the money went away.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Nobody was writing
a check for anything,
and I was like, "fuck,
"what do we do now?"
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And there was one guy
that was still interested,
so I went and met
this one guy, in a bar,
Marty Garvey, who, he said,
who's amazing.
- Marty. (laughs)
- [Morgan] And so I went
and met him at a bar,
and he said, he goes, "I don't
know anything about content."
And he goes, "I don't
ever invest in, like,
"crazy ideas," he
goes, "I invest in people."
And he goes,
"And I dunno if this will work,"
and he goes,
"but I believe in you."
And he wrote me a
check for $250 grand,
in the bar, and--
- [Gary] And were you like,
"What the hell just happened?"
- [Morgan] Well I was like,
I was like, "Is this real?"
- [Gary] "This is
gonna bounce." Yeah.
- I was like, "Is this real?"
And he goes, and he goes,
"You should put that away."
And so I folded it up
and put it in my sock,
and, you know, you ask yourself,
well how long do I
sit and drink at a bar
with someone who
just wrote me a check
for $250 thousand
dollars, and the answer is
as long as they want.
- Yeah, that's right.
- And so we stayed in
that bar and drank all night,
until they threw us out,
and then the next day
I went back to the guys,
because I already had
people in the office working,--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- on this company,
and they were like,
"Well that's great,
let's get started."
And so, and back
in 2000 there were,
there was no reality television.
- [Gary] That's right.
- That's crazy to think about.
- But there was a game show
that had just
come back to television
called Who Wants
To Be a Millionaire.
- I remember, Reg.
- And it went
from one night a week
to two nights a week, to four
nights--
- Yeah, it was supposed
to be like, yeah it was like,
it took over the whole summer.
- [Morgan] It took over
the whole summer.
- That's right.
- [Morgan] It became huge.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And it was spring into
summer, and I said,
"We gotta make a game show."
And so we made a game
show called I Bet You Will,
where I would go
out on the street
and bet people to do
stupid things for money.
(Gary laughs)
We launched the
show in May of that year,
the first day--
- [Gary] Where?
- Online, ibetyouwill.com.
- Dot com, right.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- 'Cause, by the way,
for all the youngsters,
no YouTube, no social media.
- [Morgan] No.
- You just put up a URL
and it was
expensive to stream, yeah.
- Like literally the
first day, the site exploded.
Like, word got out, like
I was getting picked up by
all these TV and radio stations,
and doing promos for it.
- [Gary] Why did that happen?
- Because the show was, there
wasn't a show really like it--
- But somebody was
the first seeder to match,
did you have a relationship,
- Well, no--
- [Gary] that
like, some PR friend,
or something?
- It was like,
somebody had seen
it, and literally called.
So like we were
out shooting one day
and the
Village Voice did a story
after seeing us shoot one day,
Opie and Anthony,
when they were on,
were like, "Oh my gosh,
you have to see this show."
- [Gary] Well that's it.
- And then they bought us--
- That's all you needed.
- [Morgan] And
so then, off of that
- They were
monsters, at that point.
- [Morgan] They were huge.
And so the show just blew up,
and the first day
it went live online
we had a
million unique visitors,
and so Akamai's calling at
the end of the second day,
and they're like, you
gotta give us more money,
to get, so I'm like.
- [Gary] (laughs) Yeah.
- We're having to,
like, pay these guys
to increase the ability for
us to serve these streams.
By the end of the first week
we had five million streams,
by the second week CBS called,
and so we ended up
selling the show to them.
They sat on it
for like six months,
didn't know what to do with it,
and then in that time,
Fear Factor came out,
Big Brother came out, all
these bigger reality shows,
and so then they're like,
"Well, we don't
know what to do with it."
We got the show back,
sold it to MTV,
ended up doing 250, or, ended
up doing 53 episodes for them,
and then when they canceled
that show in the fall of 2003,
I said, "Well let's take this
money and let's make a movie."
And we took the money
that we made from that
and made Supersize Me.
- [Gary] Wow.
- Yeah.
- We'll get into
that in a little bit,
but let's get into
the first phone calls.
Andy, get that.
I mean, like, Supersize Me
obviously was the first time,
you know, I'm, some
people know this, like,
docs are really the
only thing I consume,
I grew up on eating McDonald's
so I was super fired up.
That was a pretty
awesome film, man.
- [Morgan] Aw, thanks.
- Like, that
changed everything, right?
- It--
- [Gary] Like you,
that exploded.
- It exploded.
It, like literally within,
there was a moment at Sundance,
I remember Sundance
2004 when we were there,
where, and I had watched--
- [Gary] Is there a call-in, who
is this?
Hold on, Morgan.
- Yeah, sure.
- [Gary] This is how we do it,
we interrupt the...what's that?
- [Andy] Mel Mandoza.
- Mel?
- [Andy] Mel.
- [Morgan] Mel.
- Cool, let's
see if Mel answers.
- No way.
- [Mel] Hello?
- Mel, it's GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Morgan.
- [Mel] GaryVee, holy crap.
I can't believe I'm on the phone
with a guy from my home state
and a guy
I truly am inspired by,
and GaryVee.
How you doing, man?
- We're doing super
well, say hello to Morgan.
- [Morgan] Hey, what's up?
- [Mel] Morgan, I'm
calling from your hometown
of Parkersburg,
West Virginia, what's up bro?
- That is where I was
born, that's fantastic.
- I mean, this is
getting super meta.
(Morgan laughs)
Do you have a question for us?
- [Mel] Hey Gary...
- Yes?
- [Mel] Yes, my
question is Gary,
I was right by
Wine Library last week,
I was gonna stop in, but
I'll try to stop in this week
when I do my business travel.
- Okay, so you did not stop in,
but you still have a
chance to stop in, right?
- [Mel] I do, bro.
- And I expect you
to buy some product.
- [Mel] Oh, well.
(Morgan laughs)
Morgan, I know this format.
Gary, thank you
for taking my call,
I know it's
virtually impossible to get on.
Morgan, I have a
question for you, sir.
- [Morgan] Yes, sir.
- [Mel] You know the situation
of your home state, bro.
I mean, it's depressed,
highest overdoses
of everything,
heroin,
coal-mining industry.
There's a lot of depressed,
discouraged young people here.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- [Mel] What suggestions
would you give
for those in
this kind of a market
that are trying
to make the creative
or entrepreneurial mark?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
the biggest thing right now
is people, and
I say this about anything,
and whether it's
storytelling, making movies,
or starting a new business,
is that you can't be
afraid to take risks.
And I think that
we come from a state,
and we grew up in a
state where you know,
it is very rooted
in being risk averse.
I think that you
like to do what works,
we wanna stick with what works.
You know, whether
it be the coal industry
or whether it be something else.
The idea of trying to you
know, overturn the apple cart
is scary a lot of
times, and I think
what needs to happen right now
is there needs to be
some real investments,
some real invention,
some real dedication
on bringing new
businesses to the state,
new opportunities to the state,
because this is a
state full of people
who are passionate,
who are hard workers,
that I feel like would give 110%
to whatever that is
but people are just,
you know, whether it
be unwilling to come there
or people who live there
leave to go somewhere else
- Well, that's
the problem, right?
- like I did.
All the tech talent
goes to San Francisco,
all the Hollywood
talent goes to L.A.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- You know,
New York gets everything.
- [Morgan] There was this thing
that happened a few years ago
where I believe it was when
Manchin, who's now the senator,
was the governor, and it was
like they changed the slogan to
"West Virginia,
open for business."
And it was like this slogan
that I found to be you know,
such kind of a
Catch-22 because they wanted
to bring new
business there yet the ability
or potential, or I guess
the flavor desired
in investing new
businesses was so small,
it was really frustrating.
- Listen, Mel,
I think the one thing
that everybody has to understand
is you can trick entrepreneurs.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- Like, if I knew
that I could open an office
in West Virginia, in Morgan's...
right now--
- [Morgan] That's right.
- And I could get
a building for free
and it's
tax-free for five years,
VaynerMedia is opening up and
I'm gonna recruit everybody
from WVU.
- That's right.
- [Gary] Like tomorrow.
It's just math.
- [Morgan] Yeah,
and it's a question of
how much will the state--
- [Gary] Pay!
- Will pay
or open their doors to
have these businesses come in.
- When these states stop
spending money on dumb shit...
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- That are inside baseball and
servicing other random stuff.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- and realize that look,
this has now been proven
over the course of time.
Humans are
financially driven animals--
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- In a lot of ways.
They're artistic as
well, there are other things.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- But you know what I
love about salespeople,
they're trickable.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- I'm very trickable.
If Omaha, Nebraska or Toronto
or you know, anyplace--
- [Morgan] Dayton, Ohio.
- Budapest.
- [Gary] Anywhere,
if somebody wants me,
I'm open for business.
- That's right.
- Like Cancun can
email me right now
(Morgan laughs) and say look, we
got 10 million dollars for you
and that's what you
actually are supposed to do.
I actually think
of it like athletes.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- Like, the Cavaliers
suck until they get LeBron.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- Like the Bulls and
Lakers suck right now.
You know why?
There's no Kobe
or Michael Jordan
walking through those doors.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- If you wanna
build up the economy,
trick the economic
leader, entrepreneurs,
I mean, you could be...
Look, if they poured $25 million
into studios and talent--
- [Morgan] Well,
this is the thing...
- They could trick you to move,
you're happy in
Brooklyn but you'll move.
- You're summing
up my next point
of what I was gonna say.
This just happened as a
storyteller and a filmmaker
who's gone back and
shot in West Virginia
on at least six
or seven projects,
I've gone back home to shoot.
They've now eliminated the
film office in West Virginia.
They've cut it
out of the budget.
They've cut out the tax
incentive for the state.
So now, why're people
like me, your storytellers,
there's no incentive
now to come back.
- [Gary] And you can
only pay back so much, right?
- And they're
continuing to cut kind of
this type of economic
influence in the state.
Not just from
filmmaking, but just from
new business startups.
- [Gary] So, I would answer
something more practical,
for your question, Mel.
There's obviously the state.
So the answer is the
state has to get involved.
- [Morgan] The state
has to get involved.
- Like, period.
- [Morgan] 100%.
- That's your answer,
just so you know.
Now, the second
thing of what you can do
is groom extremely young talent.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- The one thing a
human can do is focus
on junior high and high school
and create mentorship
and like, little hacks.
Like the reason I created
The 2017 Flip Challenge
is like I wanna
inspire people like,
that didn't have as
many dollars to start
or as many
opportunities to start.
Like, you've gotta
hack at a lower level.
You're not gonna start...
You're not sending
Morgan a heart-felt email
that's gonna make
him pick up his family
from Brooklyn and move.
- That's right.
- So you've gotta start
with Morgan, 13 years old,
who's like, "Oh shit,
I can make something
"or I can do a thing?"
Like you can email YouTube
and Vimeo and other com--
there's just
pure effort of hacking
but it's reverse
engineering selfishness.
- [Morgan] Yeah, and like
that's the thing, is like,
I go back and you know,
I get approached all the time
to do things
back home, but I think
in terms of entrepreneurship
and building businesses,
they have to incentivize--
- [Gary] They have to.
- people to come start.
- [Gary] I mean,
look, there's non-profit
and that's why
you've done it, right?
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- There's non-profit.
I do a lot of things out
of the goodness of my heart.
I just think that
the way to trick me
is through the
business and the game.
You've gotta trick
through the head and the brain,
not just the heart.
The heart is able...
Morgan's gonna do a
shit-load for West Virginia
when he's 80 and he's
got it out of his system.
(Morgan laughs)
You have to
understand that's real.
It's real.
It's easier at
different parts in your life.
When you're still gunning.
Like, you know, you
give and plenty people give
while they're
gunning, but it's just
a lot easier to give...
"Give"
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- when you're not gunning.
And I think
that's super important.
That's why people teach.
That's why she's
gonna teach this year.
She's 74, she's done gunning.
And so I think, you gotta
be very practical, my man.
Understood?
- [Mel] Sure.
Hey GaryVee, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- [Mel] Hey, I bought
Crush It at a bookstore
that no longer
exists when it came out here
in West Virginia.
Been a follower
ever since, man.
Thanks for the inspiration.
- You got it, bro.
- [Mel] You've
saved my life, man.
- Thank you, brother.
Thank you so much.
- [Morgan] Thanks, Mel.
- Man, he really
drilled it at the end, right?
He was like,
"Bought it from a bookstore
"that doesn't exist anymore,"
put a real dagger
through the heart.
(Morgan laughs)
Listen, it's really ironic,
a lot of Jersey kids, my entire
high school friend circle,
60 percent of them
went to West Virginia,
which is ironic,
and also the New York Jets
drafted Gino Smith.
- [Morgan] I know, I was so
hopeful when that happened.
- [Gary] Yeah, me too.
- I was believing.
- And Anthony Beck,
tight-end, first round pick
from West Virginia.
I've got a lot of
love for West Virginia,
Reggie Rembert, if you
wanna go back old school.
- [Morgan] That's old school.
(phone rings)
- I've got a lot...
- [Morgan] Who we calling now?
- [Gary] Kimberly.
- Where does Kimberly live?
- [Gary] We're
about to find out.
He does not know.
- [Kimberly] Hello?
- Kimberly,
this is GaryVee and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Morgan.
- [Kimberly] Oh my god!
Oh, I can't believe it!
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
How are y'all?
- [Morgan] We're good
- [Gary] We're super well.
Where are you from?
- [Kimberly]
I'm from Houston, Texas.
- Very nice.
What's your question?
- [Kimberly] So my question is
I'm a writer and a poet
and the part I struggle with is
monetizing myself.
I'm very creative.
I like to say that I am
excellent at
putting out content.
I'm documenting myself,
I have no problem
being in front of my iPhone
at any given time.
I'm always writing,
I'm always creating every day.
And so my question is
I struggle with, okay,
I'm doing all this great work
or, you know, making my
work, putting it out there,
but how do
I make a living at this
in a big way?
Or how do I monetize
because I like being a creative
and not so good at
being the one that, you know.
- Kim, this is literally the
most cliche story of our time
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- Artist versus business person
and the artists
that tend to break out
either have the
business person partner
or they happen to
have business DNA as well.
The artists that everybody knows
are stunningly
salespeople and marketers
and business people.
- [Morgan] Very savvy.
- [Gary] 100%.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Morgan, I'm gonna let
you take the first crack at this
'cause this must be so cliche.
This is literally
everybody you grew up with.
- It's so many people
I meet all the time,
it's like how do
I just turn this into...
And you don't just want a job
because in the beginning,
you wanna chip away
and you wanna get jobs.
You wanna get people
who are gonna pay you to do
this thing you love,
to do this job.
But you need to turn
that also into a career.
You want it to be something
that you're
gonna get to do forever
so you never have to
offset that with job X or job Y,
you know, you never
have to do something else
to kind of offset the income,
but in the beginning,
the biggest thing is
you should take
as many jobs you can,
as much as you can,
that is in this space.
That doesn't mean you can't
still be doing other things
but as a writer and
as a creative person,
you need to be doing
as many things as you can
to fulfill that creative quote
unquote job for yourself.
And there's a lot
of people who will say,
"Well, I can't really pay you,"
you shouldn't do
those jobs for free.
Unless it's something that
you really feel like is great
or it's a great opportunity,
then you can do those for free,
but I think you have to limit
the amount of the
ones you do for nothing
because the more you
start doing really creative
or artistic jobs for free,
the more people are gonna expect
that you'll do them for free.
And I think you
have to start to build
a responsibility to
yourself as a creative person
to start getting paid
for the work that you do
and you care about.
- But I think that's right.
And I think the reality is
there's one other variable,
which is I think the
majority of artists out there
need to start
thinking about a partner
who owns 20 to
50% of their lives.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
Especially, Kim, how
long have you done this?
- [Kimberly] I've been
writing like my whole life.
I've been serious about it as
far as putting stuff out there
for about five years.
- Right so--
- [Kimberly] And I've
been super serious about it
for six months.
- Okay, so I think at
this point, it sounds like,
if you're an 18-year-old
kid and you're not sure,
you don't give up.
Don't let me come in and
take 50% of the action
'cause I figured it
out and you didn't yet,
but it sounds like
you're already at a point
in your life where it would be
a dream to be 50/50 partners
with me or somebody
who owns 20%
who's the salesperson.
I am stunned by how many artists
haven't figured out
that they have zero chance
unless they bring
in a business partner
and it's the kind of business,
when you have no money, you're
not paying some business kid
150,000 to be
your business partner,
you're gonna have
to give up economics.
- [Morgan] It's sweat equity.
- And by the way,
now let's reverse it
so everybody doesn't think this
is the business guy talking.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- The amount of business
people, probably way more
watching and
listening right now,
the amount of business people
who can't build an
interesting product
or will have nothing worth
selling ever in their lives
is stunning.
- [Morgan] There's a lot.
- And they're a lot
better to find an artist
who makes great shit
and make 50% of that,
so it's amazing to me
that the artist and
the business sales person
have such an incredible match
yet they're both stubborn in
getting to that middle place
because salespeople
are selling dog shit
(Morgan laughs)
and lose and artists are
making incredible shit
but nobody's ever gonna see it
because they
can't sell for lick.
- Yeah.
- [Kimberly] Right.
Yeah, how do I find that
partner because I really think--
- Everything you do
right now should be about that.
You should go to the
Chamber of Commerce events
where there's business people.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- Every post on social
media should be: I'm looking.
Because you know, your college
friend's brother or sister
might be that great,
but your behavior has to show
that everything you
care about right now
is finding that partner.
You could be thinking it--
- [Morgan] And I guarantee you,
in Houston, Texas,
that person is there.
Houston is a big enough city
filled with enough both creative
and business-minded folks
that you can find that person
who will be there
to complement you.
And Gary's right.
I've got a business partner
who started off 13 years ago
as my assistant, like
right after where Super Size Me
came out in theaters,
and now, together,
he's my partner.
I've got another
partner now at my company,
there's three of us
and we've grown our
company to now 65 people
so I think that
you have to look at
what you're willing to grow,
what you're
willing to sacrifice,
and what it can turn into.
- [Kimberly] Yeah, absolutely.
I'm like, "Hey,
come along with me.
"Whatever we can sell together,
"then yeah, you
get a piece of it."
I'm not sitting here going,
trying to count my pennies.
- But how aggressive
have you been
in trying to find that person?
For real, don't bullshit Morgan.
- [Kimberly] No, I haven't
because literally the idea,
it's sat with me
but I always felt like
I wasn't a
good entrepreneur if...
I was being a crybaby
if I wanted to have a partner.
- [Gary] No, no, no.
- [Morgan] It's also great
realizing you
can't do everything.
Like I'm a great creative
person, I understand business,
and I'm a great salesperson,
but at some point, you
do need somebody to help you
if you really
wanna create something
that can scale and grow.
- [Kimberly] Yes.
- Entrepreneurship is
about winning at all costs,
fairly, in a wide open game.
- [Morgan] That's right.
- Partnerships are
a huge part of that,
it's having the
humility and self-awareness.
I'm glad you called.
So, real quick,
what's your email?
- [Kimberly] My e-mail is
kimblockbeautybar@gmail.com.
- Okay, good, for the
podcast, that's gonna be,
good luck,
but for the show,
we're gonna get that email,
from Jake, you're gonna
figure that out one more time,
let's really get that
email, you've got that info?
We're gonna put
that email here.
You're about to get 713 emails
from business sales people.
Spend a month, interview and
Skype and call with all of them
and you will literally
have a business partner
in the next 30 days.
- [Kimberly] Awesome.
Awesome. I'm so fuckin-
(group laughter)
- Take care.
- [Morgan] Thanks.
- I think she
was gonna say she's
"so fucking pumped," is
where she was going, right?
I think that's what we have.
So, while Andy's
pulling up the next number,
Sundance. You can
taste it on day two?
- So here's the thing, so the
movie, the movie took off.
The movie
exploded out of Sundance,
and somebody stops
me at the film festival.
It was a movie
reviewer named James Rocky,
who, he says, "So,"
and now, go back, I had grown up
my whole life watching Sundance.
- [Gary] Right.
- It's where people
came in to the festival
with these little
movies that nobody had heard of
that literally
changed their lives forever.
- [Gary] So this is
what you were dreaming.
- Whether you're the Coen
brothers, whether you're
Kevin Smith,
you're Quentin Tarantino,
you're Robert Rodriguez,
I'd been watching this
my whole life, and so
suddenly I'm there in 2004,
and James Rocky
comes up to me and he says,
"So, how does it feel to
be the belle of the ball?"
And I'm like, "What
are you talking about?"
And he goes, "This is
your Sundance, Mr. Spurlock."
And at that moment, like
listen, I'm getting chills
just right now,
telling you this story, because
at that moment I realized,
"Holy shit, I'm that guy."
I'm Cinderella.
I'm the guy who came in
with the movie I made
for nothing, who is gonna
walk out of here and my life's
never gonna be the same.
- [Gary] And you
knew it. Right away.
- It hit me at that moment,
like, that's this is exac--
- And that's
what happened, right?
- [Morgan] That's what happened.
My like--
- Give me the next
minute, what happens
next day? Like
you're just getting pounded?
- Pounded with press,
pounded with opportunities,
pounded with phone calls, and-
- [Gary] Who was the
coolest phone call you got?
- Who was the coolest
phone call? I don't know
I mean, I got called
by a lot of movie studios,
which, as a young film maker's--
- [Gary] Dream.
- Just dream. Like,
when studios are calling you
saying, "Can you
come meet with us," and-
- You know what's
great about social media now?
- [Morgan] Yeah. And this was,
there was no
social media back then.
- What's cool about
social media now is like,
somebody uber
famous just tweets like,
"Oh my God, this
film was incredible,"
like, all the famous
people that you looked up to,
you didn't actually really know.
It never got to you--
- [Morgan] That's right.
- that they thought
your film was awesome.
- That's right, until I would
like see them somewhere,
or meet people somewhere,
and it was pretty amazing.
- [Gary] How much
weight did you gain, again?
- 26 pounds over
the course of a month.
- Oh I can gain that
over the course of a weekend.
(laughing)
it doesn't seem that
much now, in hindsight.
Now that I'm older it doesn't-
- [Morgan] I feel like
I was slacking.
- How long did you lose it?
- It took me over a year to
get it off and keep it off.
- That's the problem.
- [Morgan] Because losing is easy,
keeping it off is the hard part.
- I do love
chicken nuggets, man.
- [Morgan] I just love
fried chicken, period.
- [Gary] Yeah, I get it.
Justin?
- [Justin] Hey!
- Justin! GaryVee
on The #AskGaryVee Show
with Morgan Spurlock,
how are you?
- [Justin] Good. I'm
running out of ideas,
I just want to see
what your thoughts are
if you were given
a client that says,
"Hey, run a
campaign for us for a
"luxury underwear company."
- Okay. So, are you
on the creative side,
or on the media
amplification side, or both?
Where are you sitting?
- [Justin] Both.
- Right, so I think, and
this is men's or women's or...
- [Justin] It's
men's and women's,
even though I think there's
a bigger market for women's,
they're starting with men.
- So it's starting with men.
- [Justin] Yep.
- Okay. I would hang
up the phone right now,
and I would direct
message every dude on Instagram
that has 500,000
followers or more,
and tell them that
you need to blow up
this underwear brand,
what do they want?
- [Justin] Okay.
- And that's it, bro.
And I'm telling you
right now, you'll get
blocked after a certain amount
and you'll go to
Twitter, this is literally
hardcore knocking on doors,
good looking dude models
on Instagram,
athletes, even comedians,
even non good looking
dudes wearing that underwear,
the exposure for
the cost is so low,
and it's instant
impact on the brand.
Make sure the url on
the Instagram account
is linking to
the cart, make sure
their Instagram
account of this brand
has 15 to 20
pieces of content on it
that look the part, looks right,
and then you just
literally biz dev,
your job here is to be
the architect of the success,
not the creative
director or the media planner,
this is literally just
siphoning the underpriced nature
of personal brands
on Instagram, which is
very visual, this is underwear,
this is a fuckin' layup.
- [Justin] And when you
ask them what they want,
they're pretty
much just gonna say,
"Just give me free underwear"?
- No, they're gonna ask
you for fuckin' money, bro.
So, what you
need to figure out is
how much money you have.
Now, if you hit up somebody
who is extremely good looking
but doesn't have a
big audience, like Andy.
If you hit up Andy,
Andy how many followers
do you have on Instagram?
- [Andy] 10,000.
- Well that's way too many.
- [Morgan] Andy,
you're very good looking.
- You got most of that--
So, alright, so
Morgan, how many followers
do you have on Instagram?
Do you have any idea?
- Not that many, like 18,000.
- Great. Andy, this is huge.
So, Morgan's a perfect
example of who not to hit up.
(Morgan laughs)
He's uber famous.
No he's too famous for the
reach he has on Instagram.
So, he's not gonna
take four bucks to post
an underwear, right?
- [Morgan] Plus nobody wants to
see me in my underwear.
- I do. I do. I think
you need to have a mix
of like Ronaldo and Jake, right?
We have to like,
mix it up, right?
- That's what I think.
I think you should find
some of the people who
are the least attractive
people on Instagram and
also give them underwear
and say, and have
this campaign be like,
"We all want to
feel good naked,"
because we all want to
feel good in our underwear.
- As long as that person has
a ton of followers, right?
So like, to me, I agree.
I think you should go
to anybody if they
have a million followers.
The problem is,
they're gonna ask for money.
So the question
is, do you have any.
If you don't, you've
got to change it up again,
which is, if you want to be
successful for this brand,
you can hit them
up and say, "Hey, man,
"I'm working with this
one client, I'd love for you
"to post, you
have 87,000 followers,
"I'd love for you to post.
"On the flip side, I'll make
three pieces of content for you,
"for your account."
You've got to make a trade.
Life's about trades.
Right, we started
with this with the state,
whether it's the
state and a person,
whether it's two people with
a business in the middle,
it's all about trades.
And so, you need to
figure out the influencer market
on Instagram,
the price, the value,
because that's
where the action is,
especially for something as
visual as an underwear brand.
- [Justin] How much
money do you want
to wear the underwear?
- [Gary] I've never done a
brand deal in my entire life,
so whatever the current value
of the New York Jets is,
so for $2.1 billion,
I'll wear that underwear
for the rest of my life.
But, it's ironic, and
it's a great question,
you're gonna make this piece
of content more valuable.
I don't do brand
stuff because I've decided
to build an agency,
I've done other things.
So everybody's got
their own thing, right?
But for example, let
me give you a good one.
Braxton Miller,
Jalen Reeves-Maybin, Jon Toth,
guys that are
signed to Vayner Sports.
Because I so desperately
want them to be successful,
and to show the
sports world that I'm good,
I would do something.
Maybe I would be in
the video of the producing,
of the video commercial
for Braxton in his underwear,
which then I could
share on my channels.
There's a way to get me.
Literally the
answer to your question
is probably $500,000.
Because The Million
Dollar Man's right.
Everybody's got a price, right?
By the way, I'm not even
remotely close to 500,000.
But if you gave
one of my athletes 35K,
I'd probably give you
the same amplification,
because I need that to work.
So, now look,
those are big numbers,
you're probably
dealing with a startup,
so you have to go
to people who want
500 bucks, 100 bucks,
1000, a free lunch,
some free content,
and so maybe you're
not gonna get
people with millions,
but guess what?
7,000 here, 9,000
there, and one thing
I would highly
recommend is attractive people.
Attractive people is
an arbitrage in life.
If you're good looking,
life is better.
So you might be
able to get somebody
who has 6,000 followers.
- Who's really,
really good looking.
- [Gary] Who's really good
looking, and it just might
have the right 6,000
people paying attention
to that dude, and
so you're gonna have
to get educated on it,
but the macro answer
is Instagram influencers.
I know that for a fact.
You just have to build up
your skills on it, got it?
- [Justin] Yep,
got it, thank you sir.
- You got it brother.
Alright, let's get one more.
While Morgan
finishes off this super,
so what happened next, what
was the project after that?
So that blew up,
you became a big deal,
everybody knows who you are,
now what happens?
- This leads me to
something else that I,
I think that what people also
have to understand about,
whether it's creative
process or running a business,
is you should always,
you need to be playing
chess and not checkers.
You need to be 16 moves ahead.
You need to have a
sense of this is
what I'm doing next,
this is what I'm doing next,
this is what I'm
going to do after that,
and what I'm doing after that.
You need to have the
things in the pipeline
lined up behind whatever
this thing that explodes is,
so you're prepared to react.
And so on the heels of
us selling Super Size Me
out of Sundance, we
already knew what was next.
We went to L.A.,
I already knew we were spinning
this off into a TV show,
we wanted to make a show
where we could immerse people
into these
different environments
and force them to kind of defend
their beliefs, and
that show became 30 Days,
the show that we
did three seasons of
for Netflix, and it was amazing.
But we literally went
from Sundance the next week
and we sold that show
to FX before the movie
was ever out, before
it had ever hit theaters.
It was smart, but
we had a path of what
we wanted our,
what I wanted my career
and the next
creative process to be.
- [Gary] What's the
project you really want to do
that you haven't
gotten off the ground yet,
that you've got three
fourths of it in your head,
what's floating in
that brain of yours?
- There's a couple big,
there's a couple big projects,
there's a couple
big scripted projects
that we've been dancing around,
that knock on wood
we'll be able to pull off.
For me, to do a big scripted
film would be phenomenal.
To do a big narrative film.
- And what kind of genre?
- [Morgan] I think that,--
- [Gary] Romantic comedy,
sci-fi, drama,
- I love sci-fi, but I think
the first path in for us
before I can do the big sci-fi
that I would love to make,
is I want to do
something that's a bit more
of a comedy, like a
dramedy, something that
Something that's
historical in nature.
Right now there's a
movie that I hope we can
pull off that is all about,
it's based on a book
called Ping-pong Diplomacy
that's all about
how in the '70s--
- [Gary] Oh that's cool.
- yeah, it's like this
amazing film how in the '70s--
- [Gary] China.
- It was all about China
and the U.S. and how
literally a ping-pong tournament
was what opened ping-pong,--
- [Gary] 100%.
- opened U.S.-China relations.
- I love that.
- [Morgan] It's awesome.
- [Gary] That's cool.
And then you want
to do Star Wars 29?
(Morgan laughing)
(phone ringing)
- Well now
apparently the Han Solo
job just got filled, so.
- Yeah, Ronnie.
Ronnie. Ronnie.
You look like Ronnie a
little bit in some ways.
You actually do have
Ronnie-like characteristics.
- Yeah, we're both like,
sweet Gingers.
- Blonde, red,
yeah.
- Nice Gingers.
- [Gary] Have you met Ronnie?
- I have a bit
more hair than he does.
I just met him a
couple of months ago,
nicest guy.
- [Gary] He's a good dude.
- [Morgan] He's such
a great guy.
- Super nice.
- Yeah, he and I had a--
- Who's this?
- Hello?
- Oh, hello?
- Hey this is GaryVee
on The #AskGaryVee Show
and Andy doesn't know your name.
Who are you?
- [Bill] Hey I'm,
man I can't believe this.
My name
Tsogtbilguundari Khishigbat
I'm from a former
Soviet country as well.
You can call me Bill.
- No problem.
I can call you what?
I want to make
sure I hear this right.
- [Bill] Sorry what?
- What can we call you?
- [Bill] Bill.
- Bill?
- Or Gil?
- [Gary] Gil or Bill?
G-I-L or B-I-L-L?
- [Bill] B-I-L-L.
- Bill, I was right, Morgan.
- [Morgan] You were right.
- One, zero Gary.
Bill, first of all,
you know, I've got a tough name,
your name is incredible.
And I appreciate
being able to call you Bill.
I will practice to call
you by your appropriate name.
Where are you now?
- [Bill] I'm actually
in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
- Very nice.
So from the former
Soviet Union like me,
in Minnesota now, what
is your question my friend?
- [Bill] My impression?
- [Gary] No, your qu--
yes, actually what
is your impression, yes.
- No, no we need
an impression first.
- Both.
Or your impression on
us, and then a question.
I want both.
The impression,
and the question.
- [Bill] Oh, okay.
So I know man, so
I'm from Mongolia,
former Soviet country as well,
and Gary, you are
becoming a very big
figure in Mongolia as well.
Today is actually a
big day is happening
in Mongolia today is
a Presidential Election,
and Mongolians are tending to be
choose first really entrepreneur
- Yes.
- President
- for the first time
- Yes.
- [Bill] And I would
say like you had a great
impact on that as
well, because lots
of Millennials have
been introducing you to
the audience in Mongolia.
- So hold on Bill,
before you go any further,
I just want to make
sure I quantify this.
Are you saying that
I'm having an impact
on the Mongolian
Presidential Election right now?
- Yes, but--
- Okay.
- [Bill] (mumbles)
high but minimum impact.
- I appreciate,
I'm obviously making a joke,
but I'm stunningly flattered.
Even if I'm having a 0.0000001%,
- [Morgan] Huge in Mongolia.
- I appreciate it Bill.
Thank you for that.
And your
question for Morgan and I?
- Well,--
- Do you have one?
- [Bill] I'm an international
student from Mongolia
in the United States.
- Yes.
I'm on International
Student Visa.
- Yes
If you can say I actually
have less rights than
legal immigrant
in some situations.
What would be your
suggestion to international
student who is trying to start
his business in
United States but
trying to not
just be restrict in the
United States,
but also in Mongolia
and United States, like
try to have a connection?
- [Gary] Yeah, I think
you take advantage
of the time that you're here,
and you do practical things,
not romantic things.
Now I wouldn't force
what I'm about to say
but it would be,
the thing that
would be on my mind,
my second day,
excuse me, my first day
of high school, there
was a kid in my homeroom
named Brandon Warnke,
who I hit if off with.
Actually, I laughed at the
way they pronounced his name,
and then everybody laughed,
so he hated me
for the first day.
But later we
became very good friends,
and literally, literally I knew
that I was looking
for a business partner
in my future my
freshman year of high school.
And to this day, here
we are 27 years later,
and Brandon Warnke
runs the Wine Library,
with my dad, so
what I would say is,
while you're here,
finding somebody that
you trust that could
become your business partner,
if the circumstances
don't allow you to stay here
in the U.S., that could
hold down U.S. operations,
would be my number one.
I would literally meet people,
meet people at scale.
Every second meeting people
that would be,
the two things I would
try to do if I were you
based on the question is,
learn the American culture
of business and the market,
and meet as many people
as possible who could
be future collaborators
whether as extreme
as a business partner,
or just business connections
for the next 80 years. Morgan?
- That's a great suggestion,
'cause when I look at
the film business as is
just the investment business,
it's a very incestuous universe.
People go from
job to job to job,
and it becomes a, as big
as you think the pool is,
it does become a
much smaller pool
of people who really
have control and influence
and can help shape things.
And the more you
meet the people now
that are within these positions
or that are on
the hockey stick up,
you meet them,
they're on a track to
become a manager here,
run this side
of a division here,
invest here,
identifying those people now
as they will continue to
grow in those opportunities
are going to be the people that
five years from now,
10 years from now,
are gonna be the people
that are gonna be
running the companies
you want to work with, and
I love all the time,
how many of the
people that I started out
in the film
business now that are
really huge--
- [Gary] Players.
- [Morgan] Players.
- Players.
- [Morgan] Players at agencies,
players at studios, it's
incredible.
- Bill, Bill,
life is only
about relationships,
and it's compounded
in former dictatorships
and communist
countries where relationship
is the currency.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- You know here,
back to a meeting
I had earlier today,
where he said,
"What's amazing about America,
"is no matter
where your family start."
He said whether
slavery or immigration,
somewhere eventually
in your family line
there's an opportunity.
West Virginia is
not the hot bed right?
- [Morgan] Completely.
- Bill, I would say,
you've gotta triple down
on your relationship investment,
as many people as you can meet.
The Chamber of Commerce
in Minnesota, meetup.com,
every Minnesota meetup
that has entrepreneurs
and business people,
go to them, shake hands,
kiss babies,
build relationships.
- [Bill] Wow, okay.
I never thought
about that to be honest,
thank you guys, that's great--
- Bill,
and that excites me,
and it's funny that
I gave you that advice,
because it is a
very common cliche
stereotypical characteristic
of Eastern European
non-U.S. business people,
to not be, kind of, shake hand.
You know, we keep to
ourselves in the former USSR.
So I gave you that advice
kind of out of
intuition as well.
I don't think,
people don't realize
how much it's the people part,
and not the movie you
make, the product you sell,
the big idea
that you come up with.
I'm really happy you
called and got through,
because I think it's
great advice for you,
but I also think
it's great advice
for a lot of people
listening and watching.
- [Bill] Alright wonderful,
that's incredible.
Thank you so
much Gary and Morgan.
- Thank you, thank you Bill.
- Thank you, take care.
- And the amazing thing, since
you are huge in Mongolia,
we just made a
movie about Mongolia
that now everybody can see,
it came out in theaters,
was shortlisted
for an Oscar last year
called The Eagle Huntress,
which people should watch.
- You're being dead serious?
- [Morgan] I'm
being dead serious,
we made a movie, we produced it,
it was directed by
a guy name Otto Bell.
- [Gary] You know it,
you loved it, you loved it?
- It's a beautiful movie.
So it's about this father
who teaches his
13 year old daughter
to become an eagle hunter.
- Would it be impactful for you
for it to get a second
bump and do well on like--
- [Morgan] I think,
listen, any time as,
I love when people watch docs,
anytime anybody
watch and share docs,
I think it's great.
But this just kinda hit iTunes
and is out into the universe,
so people should check it
out, it's a beautiful movie.
- [Gary] Well so,
with my newfound
massive leverage in Mongolia,
can we make a transaction here?
Like if I can
get 7% of the upside
on the back end of this
movie on iTunes, I will--
- I think you'll have to talk
to Sony Pictures Classics
on that one.
- [Gary] Damn it, it's so much
better to talk to a human being.
Alright, we're not
gonna do anymore calls,
I think we did well there.
Morgan, given you have a lot of,
what I would call artistic
business-focused people,
a lot of people
creating content,
I said something around
documenting versus creating,
which I tried
create as a framework
of not crippling people,
and just kinda like go
reality TV doc on your phone,
'cause people
are stuck in making.
Anything you can add to
the young audience right now?
- Well one of
the greatest things,
a photographer
friend of mine said,
it's a photographer
adage that everybody says,
is like, "What's
your favorite camera?"
and the answer is
whichever one I have in my hand.
So, I think that no
matter what you're shooting,
no matter where you are,
if the only thing
you have to document
whatever you're doing
is this to tell a
story with, is awesome.
The amazing thing is,
we live in a time now,
where we used to be like,
"Oh my God, it's so shaky."
That's all gone,
like this has all
been flown out the window,
people don't give
a shit about quality,
they don't give a
shit about how it's edited,
shit about how it looks.
- [Gary] They want the story.
- It's about the story.
What's the story?
You tell me a good story,
I can put up with this.
- [Gary] Morgan, when I launched
my Wine Library TV in 2006.
- [Morgan] It didn't look good.
- No.
- [Morgan] It
did not, I remember.
- Do you remember it?
- [Gary] I do, I remember it.
- Did it catch your radar?
- [Gary] It did, of course.
- Makes me happy.
I mean--
- But it was the story.
- [Gary] Of course,
people were like,
"You look like a
hostage in the Middle East."
I'm like, "cool."
- But you were also a guy
who was waxing
rhapsodic about wine,
in a way that everybody
could finally understand.
- [Gary] Finally.
- [Morgan] But here you were,
here was some guy
who wasn't making me,
like, feel like an idiot,
for talking to me about wine
in a way that I have to
have a Ph.D to understand it.
I didn't have to be a master
of wine to watch your show.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And I think
that's what was brilliant.
- Tell me one last rant,
'cause I don't wanna let you go,
one last thing on culture,
movie-making, social media,
give us a couple 360
seconds on Morgan's head.
- Well here's the thing,
well this is for all the
storytellers that are out there,
no matter who you
are or what you're doing.
Now is the greatest time in
the history of our culture,
in the history of media,
in the history of storytelling,
to be a storyteller.
- [Gary] Period.
- There are more
places to tell your story,
there are more
places to sell your story,
there are more places.
- [Gary] Yeah stop right there,
stop right there.
Hulu, Facebook, Netflix,
I mean Amazon, it's insane.
- [Morgan] Yeah,
it's insane, you know all the--
- [Gary] Are you like,
"Oh my God"?
- It's so exciting,
to Facebook Live,
to the countless
digital platforms,
the fact that
I can now tell a story,
and reach somebody in the palm
of their hand, is exciting.
To have this direct one-to-one
relationship is amazing.
And I can make things
now that are two hours long,
that I can sell into
a theatrical release.
I can make things
that are one hour long,
that can have a traditional
television or digital release,
or I can make something
that's five minutes long,
and effect and impact
somebody in just the same way.
- [Gary] In your career, in
your balance of your career
and your family,
do you have a little
sliver that you can create
to be a little
bit more out there,
and do a podcast, a vlog,
a Q and A show?
Like I was so
excited to have you on this,
and I've had a lot of
interesting, different people,
but I feel like where are you at
with putting yourself out there,
and engaging with the audience,
where it's you, not you're
doing some interviews today,
where do you sit on that thesis?
- [Morgan] No,
I think that you're
hitting the nail on the head,
as if for so long I've focused
on our traditional production
in the way we're doing,
that this is exactly
what's happening right now.
- Good, I'd love to talk to
you off this, like I think--
- [Morgan] You guys can't be a
part of this conversation,
now it's getting interesting.
- [Gary] No you guys are out.
- You guys are out of this.
But I wish you guys could see
like how this whole setup is.
Underneath this camera,
they have the camera wrapped
around a box of Dom Perignon,
That's how GaryVee rolls.
- Is Dom in there?
- There is a box--
- There's a bottle in there?
I love it, I love it.
- The cameras are wrapped
around a box of Dom Perignon.
- That's how we
roll man, you know.
- Class act.
King of Mongolia right
here, king of Mongolia.
- [Gary] It's true Morgan,
I am the king of Mongolia.
Actually Mongolia--
- Presidential election.
- [Gary] Bud Light
Mongolian king.
- Please.
- Good historical references.
Okay, and finally,
where are you now,
so that's why I asked,
I feel like
there's a lot of people
who may wanna reach out,
this would be
their spring point.
Where is the
best place to kind of,
if they're gonna be
able to capture attention,
is it email, is it Twitter,
where is the spot to reach you?
- [Morgan] Yeah, I run
all my own social medias,
so it's like, they can
get me through Instagram.
- But where is the
real place, is it Twitter?
- It's yeah, it's Instagram,
it's Twitter, it's Facebook.
- Instagram comments,
will you see them and engage,
or is it more likely to
hit reply you on Twitter,
like which one will get you?
- I reply to all of them,
I reply to everyone,
no matter where it is,
I reply to everyone on Facebook,
on Twitter, and on Instagram.
- [Gary] Get ready my friend.
- Yeah, awesome.
- Question of the day.
- Question of the day?
You get to ask the
question of the day.
Every guest on this show,
thanks for watching,
gets to ask the
question of the day,
anything you want,
thousands of answers, fire away.
- [Morgan] Thousands of answers?
I wish I would have known
that I could have asked this.
- You could do market research.
- I wish I could have done a
little more--
- Well listen, if you
finally watch the show,
you would know how
to, it's our kinda theme.
- [Morgan] My
question of the day.
- Yeah, anything you want.
I'll give you a second here,
I'll buy you some time.
Something, you know, this
could be a good Morgan--
- [Morgan] Does it have
to apply to my life?
- [Gary] Nope.
- Could just be a question
in general.
- It could be about like,
do you like
oranges or apples better?
Or, if you'd like to be smarter,
as you can think about
the four to seven projects
that are running
through your head.
You might be able to get
some consumer
insight at scale here.
You might be able to
scratch your itch on,
maybe there's a debate that
you've had with your buddy
from junior high
for the last 31 years.
(Morgan laughing)
Maybe you're a
hardcore Reddit fan,
and there's something
going, like I don't know,
what do you got?
- These are all good questions.
- Ah thank you,
I was trying to set you up.
- Yeah but since you
talked about the podcast,
maybe that's the
question we should ask.
- I don't know, don't
look at me, look at them.
- If I was gonna do a podcast,
what should that podcast be?
- That was a very good question.
- You tell me.
- [Gary] Love it,
thank you my man.
- [Morgan] Great to see you
Gary, appreciate it.
- [Gary] This was a lot of fun.
- [Morgan] Thank you,
this was awesome.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)